[Music]
hi everybody I'm Lauren Zima and I am
about to have a moment Michael sparks
hair expert is here
Michael you have worked with Megan
Markel for years is that true yes
2006 oh my gosh and you guys were
friendly you did her hair for years and
now we're all seeing her on this big
stage as the future royal is that a
little bit crazy for you yeah I mean I
mean Megan's like a friend super cool
and it's like I kind of like grew up you
know kind of like with her and knowing
her France and now I've seen her do this
but it's it's pretty crazy it's crazy so
Michael is going to show us how to get
Megan's perfect wavy blowout you guys
have seen her where her hair up in a
little messy bun but also down in a
gorgeous sleek sexy blowout with some
wave to it so Michael let's go ahead and
get started what is the first step to
the perfect blowout so the biggest thing
when you start you kind of want to have
some organization so what I do is that I
try to forget exactly the part like I
kind of like to do it more unlike the
natural part seeing this I see just kind
of flipping it over like this I'm a
little side part girl so we're gonna go
for that there you go so what I do is I
section the hair from the ear back clean
sections you always want to have
organization when you do things
otherwise you can get lost I got a lot
of hair to get lost in yeah it's good oh
you have good hair section the hair at
the nape
and like I said you really gotta focus
on the roots when it comes to meg and
Marco though we like a little bit of
body like this is a great look by the
way I love this moment i smooth it a lot
kind of like down here for length
because it's beautiful having long hair
we like that look but we also want to
not smooth it too much at the root on
the top of the head because a little bit
you know roughness will add a little bit
more body no grit to the hair exactly
it's about smoothing the root and then
manipulating the very ends of the hair
they kind of hold so what I do I do a
round brush blow dry and like I said I
focus on the roots cuz we're at the
bottom of the hair and for the length
and then I do one to two turns to add a
little bit of body and then I let it
just kind of set
[Music]
with this middle section I'm doing it
twice I want a little bit more body
right down here at the bottom I'm not
really trying to add body at all a
little bit of body in the middle and a
lot more at the top she likes a lot of
body so as I go up I'm doing less and
less work at the root what do you think
about this one I'm doing this when I
first started doing Megan's hair though
I actually smooth the whole thing out
finally we came up with with like a way
of doing it we were like this looks
better so it's actually something that
we kind of did over the years numb up
the top so I'm gonna over direct a
little bit it so basically I'm just over
directing you know past the the part so
that it creates my body because if I was
to blow-dry it like this there's not
going to be as much body but I've looked
right like this and then I bring it down
and I'll have one body at the top of the
hair and Megan loves the body
got around the face it's always frizzy
you know you have to really put a lot of
like you know emphasis in it I mean you
have to really focus right around the
edges with a Megan we really focus a lot
right here on the sides right here and
that's the reason why I have this brush
right here this is a good brush where
you can put some product on it and
actually call me I don't know if you
ever notice you might show comb it and
then she'll actually feel it over a
little I mean I have those little baby
hairs if they're all they make that look
not so perfect yeah me personally I love
the baby years because it holds the hair
like in certain ways but I know a lot of
crimes that don't like that and Megan's
one of them now I noticed you haven't
really used any product yet so this is
really about the technics it's all about
it's all about the base sometimes you
know I use a it's called a royal blowout
it's easy it cuts the time in half with
your blowout Megan I do tease royal
black I'm trying to set your hair kind
of so once your hair gets really hot and
then it cools off it wants to stay like
that really holding it which employees
yeah I love this you are a roller right
now with your hands yeah like and I love
it how it's soft I love this softness
right here I'm not really into the whole
like flipped out curl thing you know so
no sugar is hot that's really when you
can mold it exactly
[Music]
now I'm sectioning the hair once again
horizontally sections going up the head
really smoothing down the root as I go
up less and less smoothing at the root
so I'm focusing at the root right here
around the face because he wants a
little you know she doesn't want further
on her face and everything is always off
your face but away from the face will
give it just that like softer way of
pearl versus the perfect curl so we're
adding a curling iron to the mix yes so
I'm gonna do the curling iron and I'm
taking vertical sections is what I'm
gonna do and my assistant she's gonna be
holding the hair as I go up I like to
use a little bit of product when I do
this today when I'm with your tapping
I'm so use it's just simple
light hairspray great and then I'll comb
it out when I'm done and it'll look just
look soft and it looks very very simple
and then what I'm doing is right at the
root I'm kind of just kind of teasing
stick to lightly just to kind of have
like a little like dirtiness in it
you'll see and then at the very end when
I'm done I'll even during it more but
just a light little back back teasing
nothing crazy dirty it up so what would
be the things that she would ask you for
like [ __ ] did she always want long
layers your type of cut what did she ask
you for well she likes my mushy likes it
she likes my beachy air she loves my my
layers and she loves it to be shorter
around her face and I'm very picky at
like the way I cut hair can I go in it
while it's dry and I'll shape it even
more around the face and so she likes
that she likes how like I'm very
particular and I'm picky about her what
were some products that you regularly
use on um the beach price she likes it
so messy but I started to organize it
but you know I mean I might go in there
to make sure that it's like like I said
organized chaos any kind of smooth serum
a little bit at the root a lot of food
from mid-shaft to end so this is what I
would do sometimes with her I would have
her go like this look straight and I'll
put you out all the way back so now I'm
going for like this smoother look right
so then I'm gonna spray a little bit of
like me something that's gonna smooth a
hair out a little bit more
and then I would have home everything
out they looked after me now and then I
would do like this so you would just
tell her play with your hair yeah play
with your hair I mean she literally
sometimes she would flip her hair she
would do stuff with it you know I mean
it's like and I'm like okay just yeah
have fun you should be able to like do
whatever you want to do with your hair
and we see that you know she's out doing
all these events the wind is blowing
through her hair
the Megan Marco blow out can you just
tell us kind of what your hair
philosophy is as an artist how do you
approach your client like I'm really
into shapes like if someone has a good
if you can cut a good shape and it's
gonna lay in a so far like I love that I
like I like hair that moves I'm an
ex-athlete
ex you know I was in there like fashion
and now I'm doing hair and I've done it
for a while and I love it I see why you
and Megan got along athlete the fashion
and gave up there
[Music]